hey this is presh chillwalker in this
video I will go over four questions
which are similar to exam questions you
would see about graphs of polynomials
question one
write an equation for the cubic
polynomial that corresponds to the graph
of the function shown
question two
the quartic polynomial f of x has a
leading coefficient of one the graph of
y is equal to f of x is shown write an
equation for f of x
question three
a fourth degree polynomial is divisible
by x squared plus one and X plus five
which graph could represent the function
defined by this polynomial
question four
write a polynomial equation that could
correspond to the graph of the function
shown
pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these problems
foreign
let's solve each question in turn
we want to write an equation for the
cubic polynomial
to do that we'll identify the
x-intercepts of the graph
then we'll write a linear factor for
each of the intercepts and then we'll
multiply them all together and try to
find the scaling factor of the
polynomial
so let's get started
we have one x-intercept that X is equal
to 3 and that will be a factor x minus
3.
we have another x-intercept of 2 which
will be the factor x minus 2. we'll have
a third x-intercept of negative three
and then we have x minus a negative 3
which will become the factor X plus
three
we multiply all of these linear factors
together
multiplied by a scaling factor a
and that will be the equation for the
polynomial but how do we solve for a
we need to find some other point on the
graph here we have a convenient point
which is the y-intercept so we have 0
comma 18. that means P of 0 is equal to
18. so we substitute X is equal to zero
and P of X is equal to 18.
this gives the equation 18 is equal to a
multiplied by zero minus 3 multiplied by
zero minus two multiplied by zero plus
three
this means 18 is equal to 18 a which
means a is equal to 1.
so the cubic polynomial P of X is equal
to x minus 3 multiplied by x minus 2
multiplied by X Plus 3.
now let's solve question two
we have a quartic polynomial with the
leading coefficient of one
so now we identify the x-intercepts so
we have three of them which means
there's going to be a double root
somewhere
so let's get started
we have one intercept that X is equal to
three that will be a linear factor x
minus 3.
here we have an intercept that X is
equal to zero but we have an interesting
phenomenon that the graph bounces off
this so we're going to have a double
root here so it's going to be the factor
x minus 0 raised to the second power
finally we have X is equal to negative 4
which will be the factor X Plus 4.
we know the leading coefficient is equal
to one
so we just simplify this to get the
equation for f of x so f of x is equal
to x squared multiplied by the quantity
x minus 3 multiplied by the quantity X
Plus 4. and that's the answer
now question three this is a bit
trickier
a fourth degree polynomial is divisible
by x squared plus one and X plus five so
which graph could represent the function
defined by this polynomial
so if the polynomial is divisible by x
squared plus one
then one of its factors is x squared
plus one
so we can solve that x squared plus one
equals zero will give roots of the
polynomial
so this equation has roots X is equal to
I and negative I so these are imaginary
Roots these are not real Roots so these
two Roots will not correspond to any of
these graphs as an x-intercept
so two of the x-intercepts will be gone
of the four so the graph has to have
exactly two x-intercepts at most so we
can eliminate any graph that has four
x-intercepts shown so we can eliminate
option A because it has four x
intercepts and we can eliminate option D
because it has four x intercepts so
those can't be the answer
then the polynomial has a factor of X
plus five
so this will correspond to an
x-intercept that X is equal to negative
five
so that will be option C and we
eliminate option b
so the answer here is C
now for question four
write a polynomial equation that could
correspond to the graph of the function
shown
so we're going to look for the
x-intercepts but it's going to be a
little bit trickier so here we have one
intercept and X is equal to 4 that's a
factor of x minus 4.
here we have an x-intercept that X is
equal to 2 but this looks more like a
cubic equation
so the graph doesn't bounce off so it's
not a double root but in this case we
can say it might be a triple root it
could be a fifth root or so on we'll
keep it simple and keep it as a triple
root so we have the factor x minus 2
raised to the third power
finally we have negative one but here
the graph bounces off which means it'll
be a double root so we have X Plus 1
raised to the second power
so we then multiply all these together
multiply by scaling factor and we look
for any other point on the graph so here
we have the y-intercept of negative four
so we look for negative 4 is equal to Y
and X is equal to zero we substitute in
then we need to solve for a
so we simplify this equation and we get
a is equal to negative 4 over 32 which
equals negative 1 over 8.
so one polynomial equation that could
correspond to the graph of the function
shown is f of x is equal to negative one
over eight multiplied by the quantity x
minus 2 raised to the third power
multiplied by the quantity X plus one
raised to the second power multiplied by
x minus four and that's one of the
possible answers
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time